bien lo explicaba natalio la importancia
de tener un Arquero y creo que se vio
que Argentina estaba tranquila de llegar
a la instancia de definición desde el
punto penal porque confiaba mucho en
Emiliano Martínez y su capacidad para
poder atajar penales fíjate Luis cómo
cómo son las vueltas de la vida y del
fútbol no hace creo que un par de años
cuando Se confirmó que era Diego
Martínez el Arquero que iba a ser el
titular en ese momento en la selección
argentina la mayoría de la prensa
Argentina evidentemente por por porque
dibu Martínez prácticamente hecho toda
su carrera fuera del país
decía de dónde salió este muchacho
porque este Arquero Por qué un Arquero
de boca no porque un Arquero de River no
y y termina siendo él me parece a mí Más
allá de Messi de deporte Di María de
todos los jugadores que que han rodeado
Este triunfo termina siendo él un eje
fundamental en cuanto lo anímico hay un
detalle faltando par de minutos para que
termine el partido la prórroga Diego
Martínez agarra una pelota y la tira Y
luego agarra otro y dice que no tiene
aire digo Martínez sabía que él iba a a
tener su posibilidad en los penales y
por eso estiraba el partido lo más que
pudiera porque evidentemente el tema
anímico estaba por encima el resto de
sus compañeros que estaban golpeados por
haber recibido el empate y es
fundamental es fundamental Porque además
él es el El capitán Más allá de Messi él
es el hombre que habla que arenga que
hace todo eso y y fue un Baluarte
invaluable para Este triunfo de
Argentina en Qatar no es que
definitivamente la importancia del
Arquero que quizás se habla poco pero es
como una especie de director técnico en
el campo por todo lo que habla por la
visión que tiene del juego en ese
momento pero